l'allemagne de l'est maintenant avec le
plus spectaculaire des milliers de
manifestants des dizaines de milliers de
manifestants en ce moment même je
voulais dit au début du journal à
leipzig et puis partout ailleurs dans le
pays l'installation de mesures
exceptionnelles y compris des blindés
pour prévenir toute forme de
manifestation qui risquerait de
dégénérer et puis d'ailleurs un peu
comme en pologne les églises et les
temples protestants sont devenus en ce
moment à la fois des sanctuaires pour se
protéger et des lieux de discussions
politiques voire de véritables forum
alors soyons extrêmement précis avec cet
exemple ce double exemple pris à
berlin-est par notre équipe de reportage
daniel wolfromm ahmed celle
à berlin s l'église protestante de
guéméné est au centre de la révolte
contre le régime
il est vrai qu'elle est l'unique
sanctuaire de prenzlauer berg grand
district ouvriers du berlin d'avant
guerre devenu le quartier de tout ce que
la ville compte aujourd'hui deux
libéraux et d'alternatives
ici on vient demander grâce à dieu pour
tous les manifestants arrêtés ici des
grévistes de la faim se lance dans un
combat désespéré pour obtenir plus de
liberté ici surtout les jeunes qu'ils
croient au ciel ou pas s'échangent des
informations une chose si rare en rda
mais le meilleur moyen de venir aux
nouvelles n'est-il pas encore d'assister
à ces multiples forums ici dans une
paroisse catholique réunissant à la
manière de l'odéon en 68 des dizaines
d'intervenants plus ou moins socialiste
plus ou moins religieux les débats
durent des heures il est vrai qu'ils
sont chose rare en rda les gens rient
applaudissent comme si de rien n'était
ce cas le don d'agacer les plus lucides
d'optimisme c'est très bien mais il ne
faut pas se bercer d'illusions c'est
dangereux parce que c'est une génération
et perdu tout s'en va c'est vraiment
triste tout ça
comme pour donner raison à cette femme
ces lieux de refuge font l'objet
maintenant des attaques de plus en plus
musclée de la police à berlin-est les
rues avoisinantes de l'église gets
émaner ont même été dégagée hier soir au
bulldozer
avec moi sur ce plateau daniel wolfromm
vous revenez daniel donc avec un médecin
d'allemagne de l'est la dernière dépêche
qui est intervenu juste au début de
journal parle non plus les milliers de
manifestants traditionnel de lundi soir
à leipzig mais de dizaines de milliers
sp ça veut dire que la crise est
vraiment avancer c'est intéressant à
plusieurs points parce que d'abord c'est
un mouvement de masse apparemment à la
lbci cela on assiste un véritable
débordements et plus simplement ces
quelques intellectuels finalement qui
avait lancé le mouvement et qui était
circonscrit si vous voulez au quartier
les bus les plus libéraux de berlin ou
de leipzig justement quand vous étiez
avec arme et recel donc à berlin est
classée dernière es ce que vous avez
l'impression que c'était un gigantesque
éclatement type printemps de pékin où
une manifestation réservée des
intellectuels plutôt cheap 68 n'oserait
plus tôt cette dernière comparaison
parce que on n'a pas l'impression qui
paralyse le système alexander place par
exemple qui la plus grande place de
berlin est ce qu'on pourrait comparer si
vous voulez un petit tiananmen n'a pas
du tout été bloqué pendant trois
semaines comme ça s'est passé en chine
alexander platz et occuper
occasionnellement ils repartent ils
reviennent ils se réunissent dans les
églises tout ça est un peu un peu un peu
flou pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
leader pas de véritablement de but
précis dans ses manifestations qui sont
vraiment réprimées de façon très
violente un logement si c'est la
dernière question et daniel sur ce thème
on ne peut avoir que des impressions on
va pour inventer un destin qui nous
appartient pas mais ce que vous avez
l'impression que le gouvernement le
parti sont prêts au cas où il y aurait à
débordement à réprimer vite et
sévèrement est-ce que l'impression
simplement j'ai l'impression qu'ils
veulent surtout exclure ces libéraux en
les expulsant plus rapidement possible
en en prenant le maximum au sang les
manifestations je peux pas peut pas
garantir que la répression viendra
séquence d'accord merci daniel wolfromm
de ce témoignage direct